I thought to get started there is a
question of what exactly a robot is in
2014 the first what we modern era robot
sent from 1961 the unit on the left
there which was in a GM factory in New
Jersey and these robots followed a
series of actions repeatedly one again
again again without sensing the external
environment at my current company called
rethink we have been building a
different sort of industrial robot that
is aware of its environment is safe to
be close with & a line worker not only
can be up close with it the line work we
can figure out how to train it to do
some task in in just a few minutes we've
seen this sort of thing with the Amazon
the robots go and get the shelves and
bring the shelves to the human picker
and the human picker reaches in and does
the grab and the packings and I think
this is a new sort of robot that we're
going to see more up by making the
robots be told that ordinary workers can
use our they first going to hit an
already battered labor sector you know
traditional employment in manufacturing
now that's yesterday's news that's been
going on for 30-plus years I think it's
more likely to hit in the part of the
workforce as you say that's already been
fairly hardly hit by technology and
automation it's the kind of the lower
end of the middle class is where the
real job loss the real wage compression
has happened I think that's likely to
continue because what a lot of lower
middle class workers do is some kind of
work in the physical world their home
health aides their cooks they're working
out there in the world automation is
coming to some of those change yeah but
I'm worried we're not going to have
enough robots really say again we're not
going to have enough robots there's a
demographic inversion happening where
there's going to be so many more older
people relative to the number of younger
people we've never had such a
demographic change in all of human
history before so providing those
services is going to be very very
expensive if you had to guess what the
impact of that demographic change would
be rapport with both you sir I think
it's where at least a lot of the low to
mid skilled jobs are going to come in
the years ahead it's just taking care of
Grandma with probably a robot arm that
helps lift her turn her do the work that
that's hard to do but I'm with rod it's
going to be a big source of Labor and
it's not going to be automated
existence well what's interesting is
this vision of it being a hybrid of the
robot not as a substitute but as an aide
yeah I see it as people and robots
working together more and more the thing
that I have really liked most is when
Baxter's gone into some factories the
workers have seen it operating and then
have come to whoever sort of in charge
of backstrom and said can we get Baxter
to do this job that I hate and so one
long plastics factory we're grinding the
miss form parts they have to put on a
mask it's dirty nasty job they've got to
Baxter doing that 24 hours a day now
that was at the election of the people
in the factory up until now technology
has done at least a good as good a job
of creating jobs and creating work all
up and down the income spectrum as it's
done of destroying jobs in destroying
where it's been a really happy balance
so far I personally think that balance
might be about to change but I that's
not gospel at all people have been
saying that for 200 years it hasn't
happened yet yeah we thought the pc was
going to eliminate office jobs that was
one of the things it didn't eliminate
office jobs changed what office workers
did over the long term it did change it
eliminated office yes but that wasn't
but whatever the hype cycle was way way
ahead of it and if you had bought stock
in paper companies at the time we were
talking about the paperless office you
know you'd be owning wire you wouldn't
just be reading it